abolish slavery kicked some vampire ass
now that is a president they don't make
them like that anymore I'm just saying
Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter
all right so Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter is about the 16th President of
the United States of America Abraham
Lincoln and he had a secret life in
which he was a vampire hunter now if you
remember in my video where I was talking
about the trailer I was excited for this
movie I was like this movie's gonna kick
ass I don't need it to be a deep movie
about the drama of Abe Lincoln's life
we're getting that later on but Daniel
day-lewis who's probably gonna kill a
disabled him Lincoln I just wanted to
see Abe Lincoln kick some vampire ass
and you do get some of that but it's it
well here we go this is why so revered
so what starts out Abraham Lincoln's
young and he has a vendetta against
vampires because one killed his mom and
Howard Stark from Captain America's like
hey I'm gonna train you how to kill
vampires so he does the montage where
he's learning how to kill vampires is
really cool because it's a montage
because if the 80s taught us anything is
that you show training in the form of a
montage that's how you make it cool when
he kicks vampires asses it's really cool
it's a bit bloodier than you expect it
to be no he's slicing heads off all the
cool vampire hunter stuffs going on but
then you realize something that
shouldn't matter but kind of does in a
movie titled Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter and that is that it doesn't
really feel like Abraham Lincoln yet I
mean it'll be Abraham Lincoln when he's
the president he has the beard and the
top hat and four score and seven years
ago and he's slicing vampires then right
now he's just some young dude named
Abraham who kills vampires the novelty
of it being President Abraham Lincoln is
just kind of lost in translation right
now in which case you're forced to look
at the movie with no gimmicks attached
to it what it is and that is a you know
poorly written movie about a guy that
kills vampires which kind of depresses
you you're like I didn't expect the
movie to be great but I expected it to
be more fun than this there are boring
parts in this movie and you're like
alright let's go back to killing
vampires then you notice that when the
action is going down you're like do they
have to show every scene in slow motion
slow motion is an effect like any effect
you can overuse it and it becomes dull
and boring yeah at that point the slow
motion is not special anymore you're
just tired of seeing it you just want to
see a fight that's exciting you slow
down everything you're like all right
it's not exciting because I'm seeing
that he's gonna dodge this and if you're
not thinking that you're like why'd they
slowed that down there's no reason then
at a point the movie kind of look like a
video game when he was hopping from
horse to horse chasing that one vampire
you're like this doesn't look great but
then okay he becomes president he lays
down the ax but the vampires are still
growing their ranks so as he's the
president of the United States the Abe
Lincoln that we all know he has to pick
up the ax and slaughter more vampires in
which case you're like awesome alright
it's Abraham Lincoln now this is what I
came to see on me simple money but I
wanted to see Abe Lincoln slaughter
vampires and then you get a bit of that
and then quickly you're like more
slow-motion was why why the slow-motion
I've seen the slow-motion a lot and then
in the climax of the movie the end fight
you have a lot of CGI fog and a lot of
CGI background and this entire fight
takes place on a green screen I can
promise you that and a lot of slow
motion within the CGI fog within the CGI
background and as much as you've heard
about how the Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter book kicks all sorts of ass it
just doesn't translate as well the film
apparently so Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter does have some cool parts it has
some cool action it's unevenly paced is
[ __ ] but you do have a good time in part
it has some really unnecessary gimmicks
that they overuse like the whole slow
motion thing in the CGI in the end I
will say Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter
is a good time if you're drunk yeah and
as a party up slo-mo take another shot
yeah that would be a drinking game he
would die of alcohol poisoning before he
even gets the beard I promise God
willing the universe is gracious they
will make up for Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter in the sequel slash spin-off Bill
Clinton milf hunter yeah that'd probably
be better it would right so your
favorite on-screen president who is it
comment below let me know other than
Abraham Lincoln from the Bill and Ted
movies cuz that's awesome any Abraham
Lincoln who's all like party on dudes
that's my president and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you